what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch
the trailer for The Invisible Man hmm
get it check out our patreon page
whoever I do weekly Q&A it's in TV show
reactions 3 belongs for too many shows
we need to trim it down you sync up with
a timecode and those TV shows are agents
of shield Gotham stranger things season
3 haunting a Hill House Season 1 Cobra
Kai season 2 and there are several shows
where we do have the stream along option
but we also edit reaction highlights for
so you don't have to worry about
streaming and sneaking up and those
shows are supernatural Hunter hunter
code geass Death Note one punch man my
hero academia movie included attack on
Titan in Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood he does music video
reactions weekly let's swing into action
shall we as the attorney representing
Adrian's trust contingent
they can be moved to be mentally a
comedy a lot more
[Music]
[Music]
nipple Achilles I love this this is a
great day
patrons to Dean's was how people's heads
you're saying the person
whoa upgrade action okay you can start
revealing mm-hmm sweet yeah why now
killin it mmm man the dark universe is
really shaping into something special I
can't wait for Tom Cruise to cross over
into this
oh yeah Johnny Depp looks amazing in the
lead here it's it's about time finally
we're getting what we wanted from this
practically unrecognizable well who I
wasn't expecting that I didn't do any
research on this specific film I knew
that they were making it Annie Leigh
Whannell was making it and after upgrade
pretty much him super Jack for anything
he's gonna do I love the approach
they've taken the psychological horror
approach you have this setup of a victim
who suffer from domestic violence and
this guy as they were talked about in
the trailer he's a master manipulator
narcissist a full-on emotional and
physical abuse a good idea of a victim
being not feeling like she's will truly
let go even though this person is now
dead so I love the concept of the
Invisible Man haunting her and it makes
sense why everyone would think she's
crazy
I kind of wish the trailer didn't show
as much as it did towards the end
especially when you see that he is
invisible it is called the Invisible Man
but I would have liked it if at least
going into it if they were gonna tinker
a bit with having the audience go maybe
she's just crazy she has lost her mind I
mean obviously she hasn't but I like the
game of being that audience member of
wondering that of is this movie gonna go
that route is this really just in her
head I think the setup to have it be a
personal experience for this character
it's not too big you're not overdoing it
and you still get a very personal
character journeying it a lot of horror
movies riff on the the theme of grief
right now and this is a different kind
of way to do it someone who is suffering
from a traumatic experience and
by defeating the Invisible Man she might
be able to overcome her grief yeah I
mean it's a nice visual metaphor for
sure I mean it makes a whole lot of
sense especially when you think of the
attachments we form to people and what
they leave behind in their absence and
the ugliness that that can be as well as
the more mournful heartfelt things that
that can be so yeah this feels like a
take that could illuminate some other
things under the hood of that story and
yeah I mean I think it's a really nice
twist to go what if instead of going
crazy after he figured this out this was
just a guy who was already kind of a bad
guy to begin with and then he figured
out how to become invisible I am a bit
taken aback that the movie decided to
show us what appears to be so much but I
do hope that in the actual viewing
experience yeah they maybe utilize that
kind of paranoia I'm sure they will for
the lead character cuz that's gotta
break her down some as the whole maybe
it is just in my head I do hope they can
convincingly play that note a little bit
throughout the movie cuz yeah I love how
grounded it looks the casting is great I
mean they don't really a focus on him
very much but Oliver Jackson Coen is
from hunting of Hill House and he's a
terrific actor level of like traumatic
life he had to portray in that show I
can only imagine what you know his
performance even though not the main
point is gonna be and then Elizabeth
Moss is just she's just on another level
in terms of the horrifying depths she
can go to Superboy yeah and yeah it for
the Blum House model like this is the
purpose it's funny it's like if we
needed the dark universe to fail to get
us to something like this I mean
obviously I haven't seen it yet but this
looks like the kind of thing I would
love to see more of these classic horror
movies try out is something grounded you
know yeah I don't know the you know the
the source material that the Invisible
Man is based off I've never read it but
I think for an updated version of this
to make something feel a lot more
tangible and I keep using the word
personal I'm just surprised by how
involved it is and how this seems
character tripping and putting you in
the the fearful shoes of the protagonist
it's more than just like we're gonna
watch you know cast of characters get
offed by the invisible guy and have a
lot of cool gimmicks with Leigh Whannell
with what he did with
great and then you know with his hand in
saw of being able to toy around with set
pieces I just think that there's gonna
be a lot of cool visual motifs as well
I'm also really loving the way this
movie is shot it's like yeah we've seen
what he can do with upgrade and there
there had some earmarks that I reminded
me of James Wan but here I'm even
getting some Jordan Peele vibes and the
way his direction is done the
cinematographer here looks great the
technology that we have now like the
invisible gimmick has something we've
been able to do for decades but I think
he can bring a special touch an added
layer to it that we haven't seen done
before that could feel more believable
perhaps I I'm not I'm actually really
I'm surprised by this can also play on
some of the I mean paranormal horror is
really popular and so I feel like it can
play on some of those types of images
but with an altogether different
inspiration for them it's not just a
disembodied spirits of it's a very
embodied spirit yeah you know that's
causing havoc well yes are you excited
for this take on the Invisible Man no we
are you comment below and let us know
Lizabeth and los killing it with
universals us and now back to this one
mm-hmm
she's there to Universal horror girl
Universal plumb house monkeypod chick
alright guys well thank you for being
here you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects please click our notification
bell to get notified whenever we got a
youtube video up you can check us on
patreon and like I said earlier hey
let's give a patron of the day shout out
to a man named Philip J Smith jr. now if
there's one man who has definitely
declared himself to be invisible at our
patreon page it's this gentleman right
here we were talking for a while don't
know where he vanished off to Philip
could be in this room right now
ah don't rub your was a lot bigger than
I expected it to be guys Phil has a big
[Laughter]
you